this is Grandmaster Daniel nitzki we are
watching two legends locked in battle
Magnus Carlson against Fabiana Carana in
game one of their match at the 2023
Champions chess tour finals the stakes
could not be higher and the players
making their first move very
deliberately complete chill both players
with a full compliment of 15 minutes on
their clock and a r Lopez On The Board
Magnus Carlson Castle's kingside both
players are experts on their respective
sides and Fabiano plays a move that has
been very fashionable we skip ahead a
little bit to the middle game this was
an archangel and we get to the heum the
VIN game as Magnus Carlson has traded on
G6 and jumped into E4 with his Knight
now notice the center Magnus has those
pawns on D4 and E5 he's got tremendous
pressure on Fabiano's D6 Pawn Fabiano
leaves that pawn Magnus says give me the
D6 Pawn what is Fabiano cooking up is
there a capture on H3 the G2
is overloaded and there it is Bishop
takes H3 the counter blow cooked up by
Fabiano Carana White's King is now
shattered G takes H3 and look at the the
pawn cover around White's King The Rook
jumps into F3 but Magnus he fan ketos
his Queen The Rook is under Fire the G6
Pawn is hanging and let's not forget
about the C6 Pawn which is also hanging
but Knight takes E3 and Fabby remains on
top which Piece Will Magnus Carlson take
he takes the Rook Fabby takes the Rook
on D1 complete liquidation and what do
we have on the board we have a knight
versus Bishop situation the Knight on D6
looks amazing but Fabiano says get out
of D6 he brings his Bishop back to C7
the C6 Pawn can be captured it is
captured Magnus Carlson with connected
passers in the center Carana eliminates
the Knight on D6 the one big thing to
watch out if your Magnus is the King on
G1 black does have that check on G5 in
his pocket Magnus Carlson what a move
throws in a check on D5 and only now and
does he recapture on D6 we skip ahead
once again Magnus Carlson now has a
passed Pawn on D5 but Carana has been
able to restore material equ equality
and he's got a beautiful blockading Rook
on D6 Magnus a little bit frustrated he
let that Advantage slip he's got seven
seconds on his clock and he brings his
King back to F1 to relative safety now
probably white is the one playing for a
win but things could change very very
quickly if Magnus Carlson over presses
here
the weakness of his King could
eventually make its presence felt Fabby
is also up on the clock he's got 35
seconds that's very significant if this
game turns wild three seconds for Magnus
Rook to C3 no passeron that Queen is not
allowed to infiltrate White's ranks The
Rook comes back to D3 an implicit draw
offer let's see if Fabiano will continue
to repeat moves with Queen C7 but the
Temptation for Fabby has to be to play
for a win here he's got the extra 20
seconds and he declines the rep ition
Queen D2 and Magnus he brings his King
toward the center what a Brazen move the
king and the queen are now aligned you
have to be careful about a rook
appearing on the E file Carlson drops
his Queen back to D4 obviously a queen
trade is out of the question for black
Magnus King to D2 he continues to cycle
his King from the King side to the queen
side which is a relatively safer area of
the board King to C2 and the King has
fully completed its daring walk across
the center Rook to F6 Fabby switches
from the defile to the file F3 by Magnus
sacrificing the pawn but capturing it
would have allowed White's D Pawn to run
forward after the trade Fabby has to try
to keep both the queen and the Rook on
the board in order to keep White's pass
Pawn at Bay King A2 by Magnus Carlson
now White's King is relatively safe but
if black plays B4 that King will be
reopened once again and that is exactly
what Fabby does B4 and a favorable trade
for black as The Rook trampolines from
side to side and Magnus once again with
mere seconds on his clock as he drops
his Queen back back to D2 now the King
on A2 is no longer fully safe the pawn
on B2 is very vulnerable black a double
on the B file Magnus very methodically
very deliberately parrying all of Fab's
threats Rook to D4 on the board 10
seconds now for Fabiano the clock time
has equalized Fabby sends his Rook
forward to B3 it goes attacking the F3
Pawn Magnus with five seconds what is he
going to do drops The Rook back to D3
both sides kind of repeating moves
trying to gain a little bit of time
Magnus is not opposed to a draw look at
Black's King and how safe it is in a
Time scramble the side with a safer King
usually has the Practical Advantage H4
H5 the king side is frozen Magnus trying
to find something to do two seconds on
the clock as he lifts his Queen up to D3
down goes Fab's Rook White's Queen now
drops back to D1 and the B2 Pawn is more
vulnerable than ever Fabby chooses a
great moment to double on the B file and
he takes on F3 Magnus could not play D6
there because of a check on B3 he has to
waste a move and now Fabby has captured
the pawn on F3 the attack continues he
blockades the D Pawn now with his Queen
hesitation there for Magnus as he moves
the queen up to C6 again the queen trade
out of the question in comes Black's
queen queen H2 on the board Fabby could
capture another pawn and he does Queen
takes H4 and he's threatening a fork on
C4 Magnus just doesn't have time to push
that D Pawn up to D6 now three seconds
for Fabby Queen G3 on the board will
Magnus push that pawn no he brings his
Queen back trying to find the right
opportunity but for some reason Marana
gave away the Aon there was no reason to
do that now Magnus has serious chances
Queen to D6 that Queen has been on D6 so
many times Fab still not allowing the D
Pawn to move forward Rook A4 by Carlson
The Rook drops back to F5 if Fabby can
win the D5 Pawn he basically wins the
game he's got three pass pawns on the
other side of the board and those pawns
will be set in motion before by Carlson
the king trying to use the pawns as an
umbrella Queen F6 an excellent move by
Carana Rook F3 is now a huge threat that
would win the queen Magnus moves the
queen out of the line of fire a check by
Fabby and The Rook blocks Rook D3 The
Rook trade once again favorable for
white Rook to F2 and finally Magnus
Carlson he pushes the pawn to D6 but is
his King going to get mated there's a
check on B2 the King has to run forward
King A4 another check and the King hides
behind the pawn zigzags its way to B5
Carana with seven seconds can he find a
Checkmate here the queen moves back to
A8 in comes magnus's Pawn Rook a five
check King B6 there has to be Checkmate
here but can Fabby find it with nine
seconds on the clock Rook F6 check oh
Rook F6 check is mate Rook F6 check
should win the game here and he plays it
can Carlson go King to C7 he now has 30
seconds on his clock I think King C7
might be the only move Carlson finally
slows down he calculates the variations
and I think King C7 is the best
practical attempt I don't quite see the
Checkmate after King to C7 maybe Queen
A7 check Fabby taking the time that
Magnus is spending trying to calculate
the win King C5 now Carana can win the
queen but that might not be the best
thing he can do queen C6 check and Rook
F4 was winning on the spot Carana could
have won the game on the spot with a
check on C6 with the queen and he could
have won White's Queen without giving up
the Rook now it's far from Easy the D7
Pawn has to be blockaded now the B Pawn
rumbles forward it's a three res game
two seconds for Faby a check on C7 Panic
he goes back to d8 Magnus Carlson using
his rook and using his Pawn trying to
dominate the queen now B6 would be a
huge mistake Magnus Carlson moves his
King out to A4 three seconds for Fabby
uses his own Pawn Here Comes Magnus B6
you can't take that pawn two seconds H3
a blunder he gives the pawn away with
check Magnus Carlson is gonna win B7
King E7 Fabby holding on here comes
magnus's King now Black's Queen cannot
move it cannot move because white
promotes one pawn and then white
promotes the other Pawn Here Comes
White's King rookie three check and
rookie eight is threatened rookie three
check oh my goodness Magnus Miss Carlson
might do the impossible here The Rook
from D3 is going to deliver a check to
the black king Fabby has to play King F7
there in order to allow a check on F6
and that's a huge blunder don't release
it he does he blunders rookie eight and
Fabby can't believe it King F7 would
have held a draw it would have left the
F6 where for the queen bobana Carana has
blundered Magnus Carlson has pulled off
the unimaginable an incredible
turnaround victory in game one of the
Carlson car on a match at the 2023 CCT
finals thank you so much for watching
this breathtaking display and I'll see
you in a subsequent
video